hello and welcome to this video we are
playing with two minutes advantage him
cause my opponent didn't play it after I
recognized it I thought it would be a
full fade but then he he still played so
I stoneleigh started the video in a bit
later yeah I got this on the board only
recently and i have to say i don't
really know this line 95 mmm okay uh-huh
is that so bad for black him interesting
yeah I guess this way
yeah probably you will play for quick f4
f5 yeah i was thinking i can also push
my pawn here it seemed currently f5 i
can still take i was thinking even this
move if c 3 is kind of interesting now
queen a5 isn't winning unfortunately it
looks good but Bishop c5 could be
interesting trying to trade this ok so I
got some activity going I can also
cancel now I wonder if this is may be
correct just canceling my yes I don't
know yeah just going back question is
what am i doing now like be four and a
five this is hanging I can also go
deform there may be default
whatever I Castle queenside is set
completely completely bad I'm not sure
about it it looks dicey but cancelling
short is risky as well so yeah I'm just
trying for Bishop a three-year Bishop e3
takes bishop see one that should be very
dangerous ok show me show me what you
got yeah so he moves this ok
Queen equally three doesn't doesn't help
I think I'll do this first he recaptures
wow what a viet position create is a
quite a big threat King be eight he has
Bishop f4 you can also just take a 7am
and yeah I spot this opportunity here he
had this time problems and I didn't
exploit it I feel like I had a good
position initially but of course not
anymore
I one day have some tea three could
possibly be tricky between b6 I'm not
threatening all that much time warning
yeah it's losing what can you do my idea
is d3 but that doesn't threaten much he
cannot take off course but he can just
stay and don't react e 7 d 38 Queen does
win
at least i think it does i don't see a
win for me or anything meaningful I
don't know if that was necessary might
work but
I could have one much easier but okay
it's enough okay yeah I know I feel like
that that should have been a good
position you have to see three I mean
maybe not but it felt it felt weird jun
well doesn't seem to be anything special
if you believe the engine have a pawn
for black but it's not a deep search huh
you have tried this direct way but it
didn't work really even this seems to
defend I was thinking that this would be
very dangerous but Queen f3 is winning
four wide I mean I'm ready to mate him
but he comes first okay this however
seems to work as well and she I'm
already lost according to the comp I
already felt there should be something
but I don't know yeah he's seven just
one very easily d3e eight and and and
it's over but everything winds here
obviously yeah even this but it's also
very simple for him to win
okay so i don't know this opening line
with Queenie of three I don't know maybe
this is questionable for black already I
don't I don't really know see 5 was very
very direct feel strange this would
should be good for white maybe it is i
mean if I'm not chick mating him that
this isn't this isn't it perfectly it's
not a very good structure if a check
made him fine but not if not it's not
good okay maybe this has to be played
differently ok guys thanks for watching